king payment is the demonic antagonist
who motivates all of the horrific events
seen in hereditary but the entity's
origin goes back to 1577 where he's
mentioned in pseudomonarchy demonia a
latin grimoire or instructional book on
summoning supernatural entities
according to that text payment started
as an angel where he had a great
admiration for lucifer and became one of
his followers when lucifer was thrown
out of heaven for his arrogance his
followers including payment were
banished the most detailed information
about payman's lore comes from the
lesser key of solomon a mid 17th century
spellbook on demonology the lesser key
of solomon contains info on 72 demons
and how to summon them for personal gain
each demon can be classified as a duke
prince marquise knight president earl or
in this case king each demon has a sigil
or magic symbol that represents them
which according to the lesser key of
solomon are to be made out of a specific
medal based on their classification for
kings the sigil is to be made of gold in
hereditary the stand-in for the lesser
key of solomon is a book found in
ellen's possessions simply titled
invocations and in the text we can see
bits and pieces of the same information
found in lesser key the book actually
references earlier writings from the
goetzia it's talking about ars goetzia
one of the five books that make up the
lesser key of solomon diving into the
quickly glossed over details of this
book tells us everything we need to know
about king payment and allows us to
unlock all of the secrets of hereditary
to learn everything about king payment
stick around to the end of this video
this video is sponsored by audible
welcome to horror history i always
thought it would be funny if i ever hit
1 million subscribers to do a collab
with a channel with 100 subscribers well
i did do that and this is that video so
today i am joined by my ta sarah from
the channel what the horror hello class
i'm sarah and i'm so happy to be joining
professor sisi for today's horror
history i've been a big fan of cezi's
world for a couple of years now and it's
been so much fun working on this project
i was blown away by hereditary and what
a well-crafted masterpiece it is i'm so
excited to be talking about it today
obviously i picked a horror channel that
i thought my audience would enjoy so go
ahead and subscribe to her channel
before we continue on with payman's
history let's explore the details about
king payment in these ancient texts and
how they show up in hereditary payment
is most often depicted as a male with an
effeminate face riding atop a dromedary
being a male with a feminine phase
causes payment to want to correct his
form by inhabiting a male host the
in-movie invocations book adds that king
payment has become livid and vengeful
when offered a female host which could
explain some of the horror scene in
hereditary according to lesser key
wherever he goes he is preceded by a
host of spirits and demons in the shape
of men with trumpets and well-sounding
symbols payment has a great voice and
roles when he arrives i'm not an expert
on identifying musical instruments but i
believe all of these sounds are
accounted for in the movie soundtrack
during the rebirth scene first comes the
roaring payment vocals
then the symbols
and finally the trumpets
[Music]
payment knows and can teach science art
and other secret things such as the
mysteries of the earth water and mind
give us your knowledge of all secret
things the invocations book also makes
reference to knowledge of physics and
astrology but we never see the rest of
the page payment can bestow upon the
conjurer great gifts of wealth dignities
and good familiars and he can bind men
to the conjurer as well he can also
provide an answer to any questions posed
by the conjurer you could always count
on her to always have the answer and if
she ever was mistaken well
that was your opinion and you were
wrong it is said though that if payment
is summoned alone then an offering or
sacrifice must be made
he must be observed to the northwest for
that is where he is housed we have
looked to the north west and called you
in while we only see bits and pieces of
hereditary's invocations book there are
a few takeaways such as the idea that
when calling upon payment one should and
indeed must be entirely without fear
because payment will feed on one's fear
we kind of see this play out because as
the gram family starts to accept the
idea of something demonic in their house
the paranormal activity gets more and
more pronounced it also discusses the
possibility of cementing a working
relationship between payment and the
conjurer where payment can influence
part of the person's life some examples
are given a difficult co-worker
what an uninterested object of affection
or an annoying habit are all problems
that payment could theoretically help
with we don't really see any of this in
hereditary but we do see an example of
what might happen to someone that king
payment deems to be an obstacle
while these benefits all sound great
resurrecting payment is no easy task as
we see from the struggle of his most
loyal servant
[Music]
in 1939 or 1940 ellen taperly was born
we don't know if she is the one who
first connected the family to king
payment or if it was one of her
ancestors who simply passed the
association down to her hence the title
hereditary what we do know is that she
eventually becomes the queen to king
paymon which essentially seems to mean
that she is the cult leader responsible
for making sure he's able to find a
vessel if she wasn't born as a servant
to payment i would assume that she took
on the role before getting married this
would give her a reason to have kids so
that she could create a perfect vessel
for her demonic king this however would
not go according to plan she met a man
named martin lee who would eventually
become her husband she most likely
married and had her first kid charles in
the mid to late 1960s and then had her
daughter annie in the 1970s when annie
was a baby her father martin had
psychotic depression and starved himself
to death or at least that became the
official story not much else is known
about this time period so i'm going to
infer a little bit perhaps ellen's
original plan was to use her first child
as a vessel for payment once he got a
little bit older but once he was older
he was resistant to what she was trying
to do instead she decided to have a
second child who turned out to be a girl
annie king payman did not want a female
vessel so ellen went back to trying to
have payment possess the older sibling
but at this point charles was very aware
of his mother's sinister plans for him
one of ellen's hobbies was embroidery
and she created custom doormats for her
kids annie's contains a compass with the
eight cardinal directions the north west
is highlighted in gold a reference to
the requirement to summon king payment
while facing north west charles's mat is
marked with the payment sigil and four
fifths of a pentagram when charles
realized that his mother was trying to
use him as a host for an evil entity he
was driven to suicide my older brother
had schizophrenia and when he was 16 he
hanged himself in my mother's bedroom
and of course his suicide note blamed
her accusing her of putting people
inside him after losing her son and
primary target to play host to king
payment the relationship between ellen
and annie was strained annie likely
moved out as soon as she was able annie
eventually got married to stephen graham
she means graham a psychiatrist and one
might assume that annie was able to meet
stephen as a patient receiving
psychiatric help on account of her
tumultuous past annie and steven's first
child was a boy named peter so ellen
tried to get close to the family again
seeing him as another potential landing
spot for king payment however annie
didn't let her mother get anywhere near
her or her son during this time this led
to a lot of arguing and stephen
instituting a no contact rule which
lasted until 2003 or 2004 when annie got
pregnant once again but this time things
would be different
halloween season is upon us once again
but decorations are not the only way to
set the mood one of the most effective
ways to get into spooky headspace is
with audible you know that list of the
best horror novels that you probably
should have read by now the shining
patient zero the beer street novels with
audible you can breeze on through them
at whatever preferred reading speed
you'd like the audible app makes it easy
to listen anytime anywhere like while
traveling to a haunted house or while in
line for said haunted house audible
offers an incredible selection of
audiobooks across every genre from best
sellers and new releases to celebrity
memoirs mysteries thrillers motivation
wellness business and more you'll
discover exclusive audible originals
from top celebrities renowned experts
and exciting new voices in audio members
get a free title every month that you
get to keep regardless of your
membership status if you happen to be an
amazon prime member you get a second
title every month this month i'm
continuing american psycho by brett
easton ellis to try out audible premium
plus free for 30 days visit
audible.comworld or text easy's world to
500 500. you'll find that link in the
description audible.com
[Music]
in 2004 or 2005 annie gave birth to a
second child who would go by charlie a
gender-neutral name in honor of her
deceased uncle charles this time annie
gave in and let her mother into the
picture once again which is why i gave
her my daughter who she immediately
stabbed her hooks into there's evidence
to suggest that the real charlie was
replaced by king payment as soon as she
was born annie states that charlie never
cried as a baby even during her delivery
this probably alludes to the idea that
payment is a demon with no human
emotions later we see a bird crash into
charlie's classroom window
everyone in the class jumps except for
charlie she doesn't even flinch if you
need further confirmation director ari
astor confirmed in an interview with
variety charlie was possessed from the
moment she was born as outlined in the
demonology text throughout history
payment did not feel at home inside of a
female body and this may explain why she
appears to have so many health issues
her peanut allergy is the only
affliction mentioned in the movie but a
lot of fans have theorized that she may
have elements of down syndrome or autism
and if that is the case it's easy to see
how a disorder can be triggered by the
incongruence between payment and the
female body he's possessing obviously
payment did not want to be in a female
body in the first place but ellen
realized she was getting older at this
point and she was running out of time to
try to resurrect him so she created a
plan to use charlie as a temporary host
until the colts had the opportunity to
transfer the demon to her older brother
peter in the meantime she gave charlie
preferential treatments took care of her
and even kept her from her mother even
when you're a little baby she wouldn't
let me feed you because she needed to
feed you feeding charlie may have also
allowed ellen to slip these black herbs
into her meals he means herbs the use of
herbs in witchcraft are occult rituals
are said to make a subject more
receptive to communication with the
other side and to ease connection with
spirits and demons this photo was
originally supposed to be part of
ellen's photo album which annie
discovers closer to the end of the movie
but it seems that astor moved it to the
family's fridge where we see it earlier
on in the film's run time but during the
photo album seen in the script the
picture is described annie's mother
guides a baby bottle into baby charlie's
mouth the bottle's milk is polluted with
black herbs we would see these herbs and
oils come up several times more like for
example on the doormat she created for
her kids as you would expect ellen
treated charlie like a boy so as not to
upset payment she wanted me to be a boy
i find it interesting that ellen gives
charles dormat to annie's family despite
it clearly saying charles and not
charlie almost as if she's trying to
make king payment feel more at home
despite being in the wrong body she also
makes a doormat for her friend joan who
is part of the cult as well hers is
decorated with hexagrams the hexagram is
also known as the seal of solomon as in
solomon the king after whom the grimoire
the lesser key of solomon is named
solomon is said to be the first man ever
to use demonic spells to his own
advantage jones dormant also contains
the black herb imagery seen on the
others another gift ellen gave to her
daughter was this necklace of payment
sigil ellen can be seen wearing the same
necklace it's possible that this creates
a spiritual connection between the two
allowing annie to be a victim of
payment's manipulation based on what
happens next annie is a sleepwalker when
the kids were young enough to share a
room she covered them and herself in
flammable paint thinner in their sleep
and lit a match only waking up just in
time to put it out before setting
everyone ablaze it seems that annie is
subconsciously at king payment's will
but her conscious mind is strong enough
to resist his manipulation perhaps going
through so much family trauma as a kid
and being married to a psychiatrist as
an adult made her waking mind tough and
harder for the demon to penetrate this
may explain why she is vulnerable only
in her dreams and prone to sleepwalking
this mental toughness seems to keep
payment out of her head for the most
part it's implied that psychological
turmoil makes it easier for him to
possess a victim remember it is only
after breaking peter down with tragedy
after tragedy that he becomes available
as a vessel the cult's plan broken down
into the simplest terms seem to have
three steps step one break down the
family's psyche using tragic events step
two convince them to open themselves up
to demonic possession by performing a
seance which is secretly an ancient
ritual step three possess peter so he
can take his place in front of the
congregation the sleepwalking incident
with the paint thinner is part of step
one it planted a seed of distrust in
peter towards his mother from a young
age and he would never be fully
convinced that she really was
sleepwalking this would come back as an
advantage for payment later on as ellen
got older she continued to keep her life
as a cult leader secret from her family
her photo album documents some of the
strange rituals she engaged in with
payment's cult including one where she
showered in gold coins while wearing
what looks similar to a wedding dress i
would identify this as a result of the
promise of riches detailed in the spell
book that teaches the summoning of king
payment there are also many photos of
joan who seems to be her right-hand
woman the next highest-ranking person in
the cult ellen's continued dedication to
king payment and the cult caused others
to take notice and they perceived her
strange behaviors as mental illness and
she didn't have an easy life she had did
which became extreme at the end
and dementia obviously this was just the
way that annie interpreted her mother's
communications with the spirit world
everyone in the family tree with the
blood of relation to ellen is diagnosed
with some kind of mental illness at one
point or another from the outside it
would appear that it runs in the family
that it's hereditary but it seems very
likely that each case was actually a
reaction to demonic activity that was
interpreted as mental illness because of
the guilt she felt about their
relationship annie took her mother in to
live at the house with them near the end
of her life she stayed in an extra
bedroom at the end of the hall where she
carved this triangle onto the floor it's
pointed diagonally which made me wonder
if this was another sign to look to the
northwest looking for answers online
brought me to the movie script which
does indeed specify that the triangle is
pointed northwest triangles also seem to
be an important part of the spellbinding
process when we see the ritual in
progress in joan's apartment a photo of
peter is placed inside a triangle that
has been crudely carved into the kitchen
table long story short ellen had been
performing demonic rituals in her room
while living at the house annie is a
professional artist who makes miniatures
of many scenes from her and her family's
life as far as we know these are all
real moments that she's recreating one
miniature we only see in passing is this
one depicting ellen standing in stephen
and annie's doorway like a ghost in the
middle of the night does this mean that
ellen was also a sleepwalker is this
another traits that was passed down to
annie or was ellen attempting to do
something to them as they slept perhaps
something involving dark magic if that
is the case it would not be her first
time ellen's photo album contains
evidence that she used a family photo of
stephen annie peter and charlie as part
of some candlelight ritual with the cult
this could explain the bizarre series of
events that seems to be aimed at the
graham family shortly after ellen's
passing
[Music]
before her mortal body fails her ellen
writes a note to her daughter which
vaguely alludes to the benefits of
resurrecting king payment though in
order to make sure that her plan goes
off undisturbed it does not mention any
of the specifics like her involvement in
cult activity the card reads my darling
dear beautiful annie forgive me for all
the things i could not tell you please
don't hate me and try not to despair
your losses you will see in the end that
they were worth it our sacrifice will
pale next to the rewards love mommy as
her health declined she was moved to
hospice before her death on april 3rd
2018. her funeral was held at spring
blossom cemetery on saturday april 7.
that morning charlie sleeps outside in
the tree house her father scolds her for
this saying that she'll catch pneumonia
to which she responds that's okay it
seems payment could be aware that he'll
soon be able to ditch this vessel later
that morning many of the cult members
showed up to mourn their queen
unbeknownst to the family who assumed
that they were ellen's friends during
the viewing ceremony one of the cult
members smears something on ellen's lips
in the movie it's difficult to see
exactly what she's smearing but the
script once again adds more
clarification an older woman arrives at
the open casket her finger is dipped
into a small bottle of oil she quickly
and covertly streaks the oil along the
corpse's lips there are other instances
in the script where annie discovers
bottles of oil and herbs in the box of
her mother's old possession so i think
this oil serves a similar purpose to the
herbs seen in charlie's bottle to help
make it easier to communicate with the
spirits that night while putting her
daughter to bed annie notices the word
satany written on charlie's wall satany
is a word associated with invocation or
the calling upon a demon or supernatural
entity specifically it seems to be used
for necromancy rituals necromancy is the
act of communicating with the dead
shortly after annie discovered the card
left by her mother she turns the light
off and sees her ghost standing in the
dark the inclusion of satany on
charlie's wall may not just be for her
to communicate with ellen but
potentially all of the cult members who
are now staying close outside the house
at times you can hear what sounds like
the echoes of ritualistic chanting
[Music]
at night we see someone breathing
outside of peter's window and charlie
comes across a strange woman burning
something in the field outside their
home all of these forces are at play to
ensure that the entire ritual goes
according to plan the revival of payment
at the expense of the graham family is
analogous to the heracles discussion in
peter's english class heracles was a
hero in greek mythology peter's
classmate explains that heracles fatal
flaw is arrogance because he literally
refuses to look at all the signs that
are being literally handed to him the
entire play throughout hereditary we see
clues that the family is being
manipulated by this demonic cult but
most of the viewers won't recognize them
on first watch or before watching things
you mess however the english teacher
reminds the class that the author
sophocles wrote the oracle's vision as
absolute meaning heracles could not have
avoided his fate no matter what so the
discussion shifts to a debate about if
this is more or less tragic than a story
where the characters have agency i think
it's more tragic because if it's all
just inevitable then that means that the
characters had no hope they never had
hope because they're all just like
hopeless pawns in this horrible hopeless
machine the graham family was destined
to go through these tragedies because
their world is being manipulated by
payment the girl in peter's class calls
the oracle characters pawns and we could
also apply the chess metaphor to
hereditary where the characters are
pawns to the desires of king paymen and
queen lee that afternoon charlie
collects the bird that crashed into the
window during her class and cuts off the
head for later use in one of her crafts
this is the first example of
decapitation which is the one aspect of
king payment in the movie that doesn't
seem to be derived from the lesser key
of solomon or any of the other grimoires
or ancient texts that mention him it
also foreshadows the ending where
charlie's own head would be placed upon
a mannequin to serve as a demonic idol
the invocations book found in ellen's
box does contain a drawing of payment
riding on the dromedary with three heads
as cargo this must be connected to the
three generations of women who are
decapitated over the course of the story
birds also seem to be a special symbol
for king payment almost as if he
associates himself with a great bird
charlie draws a picture of a bird
wearing a king's crown in her sketchbook
she has artwork of a bird beside her bed
her desk is filled with sticks and nests
and the treehouse where she likes to
spend most of her time resembles a
birdhouse the cult moves swiftly after
the burial to recover ellen's body
because it would later play an important
role in the invocation ceremony for the
time being they stash it inside the
graham's attic a week after her mother's
death annie attends a support group if
this is exactly one week later the date
is tuesday april 10th which means that
we're coming up on friday the 13th that
seems fitting considering that friday
the 13th and occultism are both only
observed by these superstitious careful
zack you don't want to piss off the
non-skeptics like last time
[Music]
when charlie is working on her craft she
sees this light flare travel across the
room and direct her attention to the
window everyone is going to have their
own interpretations about what this is
personally i see it as the life energy
of an entity with no human vessel and i
believe we see multiple entities travel
in this form in this case it's ellen who
is trying to point something out to king
payment who is still inside of charlie
we see the light flare closing on the
window and charlie gets up to look out
that window before going outside towards
the treehouse that night charlie goes
with peter to a school party on the way
there they drive past a telephone pole
with the payment insignia carved into it
suggesting it was always the colt's plan
for charlie to be killed at this spot at
the party peter goes into a private room
with friends where two kids are watching
a decapitation scene from an old movie
like heracles peter was being given many
signs about the impending tragedy but
was still powerless to prevent it
charlie eats a cake with nuts seemingly
way too many nuts i think any cake with
nuts has too many nuts but in this case
the cake triggers her allergies so peter
tries to rush her to the hospital but a
deer in the road causes him to swerve
out of the way while she's sticking her
head out the window for air the
telephone pole cleanly knocks the head
off of her shoulders and with that the
first part of the colt's plan was all
but complete payment was now released
from the confines of charlie's female
body and this loss would send the family
spiraling to use peter's school lessons
as an example again it was a great crash
which led to a great depression in the
family someone from the cult would go to
retrieve the head at some point for
later use the family's reaction to
charlie's death is very different than
the reaction to ellen's everyone in the
family is completely destroyed which
seems to be a part of the plan as we
mentioned above it seems like you have
to be mentally deteriorated or broken
before the demon can possess your soul
we've seen similar ideas expressed over
in the conjuring franchise which also
deals with demons from the lesser key of
solomon usually ed and lorraine warren
come to a family to investigate the
paranormal but we also see them mend
issues in the family's day-to-day life
boosting their morale and making them
stronger in their fight against the
demonic entity hereditary lacks any
psychic superheroes and there's not
really anyone to help the grams make it
through their tragedies after the
funeral stephen discovers the word
zaza's written on the wall in their
bedroom this is another invocation term
left by the cult zaza's is similar to
zaza or zozo which is part of a supposed
phenomena among ouija board users where
upon asking who they are speaking to the
board would spell out z-a-z-a or z-o-z-o
this is essentially evidence that the
cult has been in the house to
communicate with the other side the
family was right where the cult wanted
them and their desperate hour would lead
to the most disturbing set of
circumstances yet
[Music]
annie desperate for some kind of last
connection to her late daughter sleeps
in the treehouse outside and uses space
heaters to keep warm which emit a red
glow reminiscent of the fires of hell
like everything we've seen so far this
has a purpose it foreshadows the use of
the treehouse as a demonic chapel at the
end of the story the next time annie
visits the support group joan makes a
move to get close to her and gain her
trust by introducing herself and making
herself relatable by saying her son and
grandson drowned a few months ago
neither me or cece are particularly
convinced that joan ever even had a son
and grandson but we'll get into that
joan needs annie to open her family up
to the occult by performing a ritual
herself so she positions herself as a
friend in order to eventually encourage
her a day later one of the cult members
slips a flyer about the open seance into
the graham's mail slot but it gets
ignored so joan switches to plan b
continue to freak annie out as she's
working on her miniatures some
supernatural force knocks over one of
her paint bottles i guess we could call
this a tiny little air yet
the spill directs her attention to the
slip of paper with joan's number so
annie finally decides to visit her joan
makes her tea and when annie drinks it a
black herb gets stuck to her lip the
same herb seen before in charlie's
bottle meant to make the subject more
receptive to necromancy joan is
essentially buttering her up to be
possessed by an evil spirit look at how
her eyes dart to the teacup when annie
puts it down checking to make sure she
consumed what she was supposed to during
their next encounter joan tells annie
that a medium came over and conjured her
grandson she demonstrates the ritual
where annie sees a glass slide on its
own something blows on annie's hair and
some supernatural entity writes the
words i love you grandma on a chalkboard
she tries to make annie believe that her
grandson is doing all this but i
personally think that there is no
grandson and payment spirit is
responsible i say this because most
seven-year-olds probably wouldn't be
this bad at spelling maybe i'm wrong but
ari astor has also stated it's a piece
of misdirection it plays as a science
scene but it's really a much darker
conjuring and they need annie to take
part in it in order to bring it into the
house and in order to further this
ritual along when she invites it in she
escalates things so that's exactly what
happens joan explains how annie might be
able to talk to her own daughter first
light the candle
then choose an item that belonged to
your daughter that will be your link
mine was the chalkboard that's my link
it's all right it's all right
it's okay
there you go then when you're ready
read this out loud
every syllable the inscription is in a
different language joan acts like she
doesn't know what it is but again i
think she's probably lying and she
mentions that every member of the family
needs to be in the house probably to
ensure that she can curse all of them
while driving home annie hears the
sound that charlie used to make telling
us that payment spirit is with her she
wakes everyone up to perform the seance
they see charlie and move the glass on
the table open the cabinet door and
toggle the flame on the candle of course
this is not really charlie this is king
payment responding to the dark ritual
that annie's performing and as a result
he possesses the body of annie causing
her to emit this creepy demonic sounding
noise
before taking over her body and
seemingly speaking as charlie
hello mom
mom i'm not sure if this is payment
taking a moment to adjust to being in a
new body or if payment is acting like
charlie to deliberately freak out peter
but it doesn't really matter because
peter absolutely gets freaked out this
does raise the question if payment wants
to inhibit a male body why does he first
go for annie not peter i think it's
because peter essentially wasn't ready
yet and he had been driven to madness by
that month's events peter was
psychologically damaged but hadn't quite
completely lost his mind yet and he was
also made more vulnerable by drinking
the herb spiked tea from joan and being
the one to physically perform the ritual
because she believed that she could talk
to charlie again by possessing annie's
body it would be a lot easier for
payment to continue to freak out peter
and drive him to the point where he can
also be possessed you could argue that
peter was also buttered up to be
possessed using the black herbs because
he's shown to have a bag of marijuana
that he smokes with friends you could
certainly make the case that the cult
slipped something in there but then
again when peter starts seeing the light
in class we never see his friend react
it also appears that payment doesn't
permanently possess annie she seems to
go back to normal after steven pours a
glass of water in her face it seems that
payment doesn't use her again until
later my thought is maybe he goes
dormant inside of her until the time is
right at this point the words lift touch
and pandemonium appear on the wall in
the hallway lift touch appears to be a
rough english spelling of a hebrew word
leaf toe which means open and
pandemonium as you probably know means
chaos or mayhem when we put these
together the phrase describes how the
family has now opened themselves up to
the chaos and mayhem of hell this idea
was confirmed when in his reddit ask me
anything aries said that lyft oak
pandemonium translates as open up to
chaos i don't know who runs the
hereditary subreddit but a huge missed
opportunity not naming it hereditary
redditors would you expect there also
may be a dual meaning behind pandemonium
the word was originally coined in 1667
by english poet john milton in his poem
paradise lost the studio came to me with
stan no
not that john milton the story
references lucifer's rebellion in heaven
and subsequent banishing at the
suggestion of one of lucifer's followers
the fallen angels build pandemonium a
temple in the capital of hell the word
was crafted by joining pan a greek word
for all and demonium which is apparently
latin for evil spirit creating a place
for all demons the word has evolved over
the years with its meaning ranging from
a place of disorder to lawless confusion
much like los angeles it's probably also
around this time when joan sets up a
ritual in her kitchen with the intention
of targeting peter the room is covered
in candles and draped in white sheets
peter's photograph is taped to an idol
in front of some kind of dish as well as
in the center of this triangle as
previously mentioned we also see a crude
miniature version of the treehouse
chapel scene foreshadowing the rebirth
at the end of the movie the bird that
charlie decapitated at her school is
mounted to one of the toys she used to
tinker with this represents the idol
affixed to her own head the animals
surrounding it represent her worshippers
bowing down to her in the treehouse it
seems that annie is not the only one
interested in creating miniature
dioramas this creates an interesting
parallel annie loves to create and
manipulate these miniature scenes of
moments from her and her family's life
she believes that she has control over
these scenes but in reality she is the
one being controlled and manipulated by
payment in the cold we see this in the
way that the exterior shots of the house
are photographed cinematographer powell
porgerzelski uses a tilt shift lens for
many of the establishing shots this type
of lens is known to make its subjects
look like miniatures it's a subtle
suggestion that annie and her family are
actually the ones being manipulated the
lesser key of solomon mentions one of
the benefits of summoning payment is his
knowledge in art just as annie is an
artist manipulating miniature scenes
think of ellen as an artist manipulating
her family the next day payment would
continue to torture peter in new
inventive ways one of which plays on
another ancient superstition
[Music]
during history class peter sees the
payment light flare and it directs his
attention to the cabinet next to him
where his own reflection stares back at
him with an evil grin one interpretation
of this is that the grin in reflection
that we see is in fact payment for
centuries mirrors and reflective
surfaces have been believed to be
incredibly powerful objects because of
their dual nature of being one part in
the real world and one part in the world
of celestial reflections they are
sometimes considered to be a boundary
between the material and supernatural
world mirrors have been thought to
harness a variety of powers from being
used as a tool to scry or see into the
future to trapping the soul of the
recently dead and being a portal similar
to those seen in alice through the
looking glass there are plenty of
examples of the power of mirrors across
films and literature whether it's
vampires having no reflection or calling
on candyman or bloody mary peter nearly
has a heart attack after hearing the
pain and clicking sound that he
associates with his dead sister
this weird experience gives him the idea
that he's being haunted peter just
called me annie terrified crying in the
halls convinced he's being threatened by
some vengeful spirit in the night annie
finds charlie's sketchbook drawing up
pictures of peter all on its own peter
is awoken by the click sound and he sees
a horrifying vision of charlie standing
in his room and losing her head the
family dog seems to react to this
causing him to growl and bark an example
of the trope of animals being able to
see supernatural happenings that humans
cannot which also came into play when i
talked about the conjuring just then a
phantom pair of hands grabbed peter by
the head and tried to yank it off this
was most likely just a tactic to scare
him and further turn him against his
mother who had rushed into the room
because of the commotion in an attempt
to put an end to all of the paranormal
horrors annie throws charlie's
sketchbook into the fire because she
believes that it is the item that
connected her to the world of the dead
and opened the family up to
communication with some other spirit
however her own sleeve simultaneously
catches fire demonstrating that she is
now linked to the evil in the house
desperate for answers she tries to visit
joan the next day but she isn't there
probably because she's at peter's school
trying to expel his own soul from his
body to clear the way for king payment i
expel you
sadness
agony
a paragon
peter
get
out
back in school he continues to be
distracted by the wave of light which
must be payment pointing him in the
direction of the classroom where he
completely loses it he hears charlie's
clicking sound from all directions
before his body contorts and he
involuntarily slams his face into the
desk and breaking his nose meanwhile
annie sorts through her mother's old
possessions leading her to discover
ellen's involvement in the occult and
friendship with joan she also comes
across her mum's body rotting in the
attic decapitated and dressed in a gown
with the payment sigil very likely
embroidered by ellen herself the symbol
is also painted on the roof of the attic
and she finally makes the connection
that this icon matches the necklace
given to her by her mother she still
believes that burning the sketchbook is
the key to stopping the demonic
infestation but when she tosses it in
the fire her husband is the one to go up
in flames i see this as a statement from
payment he's sending a message to the
family that they have no control over
outcomes they're not going to win so
they may as well give up and allow the
possession to take place and that's
exactly what happens payment travels to
her in lightfly form and we see her
expression change from mortified to
blank much like the blank expression
that was always seen plastered on
charlie's face using annie payman would
pull out all the stops to get to peter
he awakens in the middle of the night to
see an orange glow coming from the
treehouse perhaps orange is payment's
favorite colour based on the fact that
he always wore an orange sweater while
possessing charlie his mother's body
swims through the air in the background
defying gravity an example of the hints
from the invocations book that payments
abilities include manipulation of
physics peter comes down to find the
house totally disheveled and his dad
burnt to a crisp in front of the
fireplace meanwhile his mum is lurking
on the ceiling behind him and the creepy
smiling man from the funeral is naked in
the closet doorway with the sinister
grin still not erased from his face he
turns back at a noise and his mom is
gone having climbed over to the other
corner she rolls and runs towards him
causing him to run away into the open
attic and lock himself in annie climbs
onto the ceiling and repeatedly bashes
her head into the door the whole attic
is illuminated in candles and the spot
where joan's body had been kept now
contains the photo of peter this time
with his eyes burned out just like the
photos that appeared in charlie's
sketchbook rumor has it that the
original ending involved peter losing
his eyes which probably ties into the
old saying eyes are the windows to the
soul even though peter doesn't end up
losing in the movie i think this imagery
still works on a symbolic level after
hearing a fleshy noise peter looks up to
find his mother floating above him
sawing her own head off with a thread
she stares intently at him more
unclothed cult members suddenly populate
the attic and this seems to be the exact
point where peter loses it and he jumps
out the window as he's lying there the
beam of light floats over and lands on
him it seems to be absorbed into him
which i think is the most convincing
evidence that the light flares we've
been seeing are spirits without a body
to reside in in this case king payment
annie floats into the treehouse and
peter makes the clicking noise
confirming that at long last the king
has finally managed to possess his male
host he climbs into the treehouse where
there is a ritual in progress rows of
people are bowing down he sees the
mannequin at the altar charlie's head
wears a strange crown and behind that is
a sunburst pattern the same one seen on
the cover of the invocations book seeing
this now brings to mind the sun gate
from arya astor's second film midsummer
which also had a triangle-shaped temple
not unlike the triangle we saw in
ellen's room and throughout the movie
the mannequin is embossed with the
payment sigil and stands beside a bird
cage containing a live bird we already
discussed the significance of birds for
king payment joan places the crown on
peter's head and assures him that
everything is all right now that he's
taken on his proper mail form
you
are payment one of the eight kings of
hell in the lesser key of solomon a
payment is described as one of the nine
kings of hell i wonder if this change
was made to give more meaning to the
requirement to face northwest when
calling upon payment that way each king
is in charge of one cardinal direction
we reject the trinity
and pray devoutly to you great payment
give us your knowledge of all secret
things bring us honor
wealth
and good familiars bind all men to our
will
as we have bound ourselves for now and
ever
to yours with all three steps complete
the cult has completed the transfer of
vessels and payment can lead from his
desired male body as for the gram family
they really were just pawns in a
horrible hopeless machine which brings
me to the same question posed by peter's
english teacher does the locked fate of
the family and inevitable triumph of
king payment make this story more tragic
or less tragic i want to give a huge
shout out to sarah from what the horror
without her research and analysis this
video would not have been possible at
all what the horror is one of the best
up-and-coming horror movie channels she
does reviews rankings and my personal
favorite truly horror tuesdays where she
goes over the behind the scenes stuff
that is sometimes stranger and scarier
than the movies themselves she just
released her own video on hereditary
versus midsummer a comparison of artie
astor's first two films which you can
check out by clicking on that video on
the left be sure to drop her a sub ring
the death bell and select all
notifications and we will see you in the
next video assuming we both survived
[Music]
you